Film Courage: What was your first success
as a screenwriter?
Gordy Hoffman, Bluecat Screenplay Founder/Screenwriter:
Well my first obvious success was LOVE, LIZA.
Writing my second script I wrote was a drama
I wrote it in ’96 (the fall of ’96) and
6 years later at Sundance it won at Sundance
the Waldo-Salt award and it was bought by
Sony Classics and released by Sony and.
That was definitely the first sort of obvious
success.
I mean I had other things like options and
things but that was sort of like the conspicuous
success and my little brother I showed it
to him Labor Day Weekend 1996.
We were both back at my mom’s house and
we both happened to be there and I said “Oh
man you’ve got to read this.”
And I had just written the first draft and
I said “I think this is kind of good.”
And I said “I don’t know?
I think this is kind of cool.”
He read it and he was like “I want to do
this!”
And he had not shot BOOGIE NIGHTS yet.
He was about ready to shoot BOOGIE NIGHTS
that fall.
So that fall he shot BOOGIE NIGHTS with Paul
Thomas Anderson.
Paul Thomas Anderson read LOVE LIZA and actually
gave it to Michelle Satur at Sundance and
they considered it for the lab (the Sundance
lab).
So that was very exciting.
I ended up moving out to LA in February of
’97 and then we started the process of trying
to get the movie made.
Eventually we shot in 2001.
Kathy Bates was in it.
All that stuff felt successful.
The idea that Sundance was interested and
it was great because I just had a short film
that I wrote and directed in 2015 and Michelle
Saturs is still there and she came up to me
and we still know each other from when she
called me on the phone and I was in Upstate
New York in the fall of ’96 and she interviewed
me about LOVE, LIZA and Paul had referred
the project to them and she said “Hey you
should check this out.”
And she responded to the script, it didn’t
get in but they were always tracking it and
then obviously it was accepted.
Paul’s movie HARD 8 was developed.
It was originally called SYDNEY and his first
feature was developed through the Sundance
lab.
So that was the relationship with the lab
that Paul had.
So all that stuff was exciting but the most
popular thing that people would say is “Oh
Sundance, winning the award” Or whatever
but there was many other things that populated
my professional career that were like “Oh
this is exciting!”
Film Courage: When you sat down to write LOVE,
LIZA was that in your mind that it was going
to have a trajectory like that?
Gordy: Okay so I sat down to write LOVE, LIZA
and you know I had been driving a cab for
three and half years in Chicago and I had
just quit like a month before because I had
sideswiped a limousine and I was like sort
of having this mental breakdown or whatever
and I was just like “I just want to write.”
And my family gave me just a little bit of
rent money.
So that summer I just didn’t work and I
was like I’ve got to do something and so
I remember August 5th (it was very clear),
I woke up and I had written 2 pages of it
and I wrote in like 18 days.
I just sat there and wrote the whole thing.
And I always wrote it with the sense that
I would play the guy…or not that I would
play the guy but I did write it with the sense
of “What if I was going to play the guy?”
And that really helped me as a writer you
know?
It was like it really got me.
I’d never really done that much a lot since
then but I should probably think about the
sometimes because it was really effective
like “What if I play this guy?”
It was like this Orson Welles-ey sort of thing
like “I’m going to do everything.”
Like sort of when I was a kid.
So I wrote it like that.
I didn’t write it for my brother.
And I showed it to my brother because I was
like “This is good man!”
And I knew it was good.
And I gave it to him at 10:30 at night and
he read it and the next day he was like “I
just read the whole thing.”
And he totally responded to it “I want to
do it.”
And I think it was like historically you look
back and I guess it was like two brothers
making this movie together but my brother
ended up being Phillip Seymour Hoffman and
doing all of these other things so historically
it looks like one thing but he actually was
just an actor who was like “I want to do
this role.”
Because it was a cool role, it was hard as
sh*t.
But he liked it.
And then we went on this journey together
and so yeah…I’m not sure what the question
was, but that’s what it was?
Film Courage: Did you expect this kind of
journey and it sounds like no that wasn’t
it?
Gordy: It was like no, you don’t expect
that sorts of things and then I didn’t expect
it would take so long to make it.
There were so many things you were like “Oh
my gosh?”
And you didn’t expect it to not do all sorts
of things.
But we’re very lucky because we made a film
that there’s plenty of people that it’s
their favorite film.
And I always tell people that the greatest
success is if you can write somebody’s favorite
film.
If
you write something and that’s their favorite
film it doesn’t get any better than that.
You’re never going to get everybody to like
your film.
And the money is going to always disappear
and I still have people coming up to me and
are moved by the film, tear up when they talk
about it and go “Oh my God, you wrote LOVE
LIZA and it means something to them and I’m
fortunate because that’s the kind of thing
that has guided me because it’s like nothing
else matters except giving your audience that
experience and if you get that to people and
some people will think it is crap or whatever
and some people will think it’s a nepotism
job or whatever or it’s like flimsy or whatever.
It doesn’t matter because it’s a personal
experience, films are personal.
There are plenty of people that I love CITIZEN
KANE.
I think it genius and other people just hate
it.
And it’s like there you go.
Film Courage: Were you thinking about the
characters while you were driving (before
the limo accident)?
Gordy: I came up with the idea for LOVE LIZA
because when I was driving a cab I came up
with ideas all the time.
And it was one of those ideas, I just saw
a woman, she was homeless, she was by the
gas pumps at a has station (as a taxi driver
you’re living at the gas station a lot,
you’re always there).
And I her saw her and it was like and it just
put in my mind this idea of a yuppie (which
is not an acronym that is used anymore)…it’s
like a professional white guy in a suit suddenly
starting to huff gas.
I just started seeing this guy huffing gas.
That was the germ of the idea and then I had
to come up with a motive and then I came up
with the motive and I started writing it from
there.
And then I started creating everything from
there and I came up with sort of a MacGuffiney
hook so to speak at around 10 minutes in the
movie and it’s that hook that sort of drove
and then like I said I just sort of splatted
it out.
And honestly it probably could have been rewritten
a bunch more times.
But it did get rewritten and I did fix a little
bit as a baby writer then so…that’s where
it came from.